what was the darkest time in your life
and what did your road to recovery look
like
in general i love life so it's difficult
for me to talk about these kinds of
things
but let me briefly say that i think
the darkest times have been when i've
put my faith
in people when i opened my heart to them
and they turned out not to be
the best versions of themselves or maybe
the kind of amazing
people that i hope i thought they might
be
so my heart has been broken in
small ways in my life as i'm sure it has
been for many people
but the fire of hope
still burns bright perhaps even brighter
you mentioned road to recovery i think
with the people i mentioned i
focus on the positive moments and there
always are
and just have gratitude for those
and just don't linger on the negative i
just remember the good times
that's how i recover that's how i keep
my optimism and that's how i
keep my heart open for future amazing
people
to take the risk and i'm sure my heart
will be broken again
perhaps many times in the future but i
think it's always worth the risk
i like the i wrote this down the marcus
aurelius quote love the people with whom
fate brings you together
and do so with all of your heart i think
that's all we can do
you